et clovis alors qu'est ce qui vous a
donné envie de réaliser balle et
sébastien parce que d'habitude vous
réalisez vos propres films
ben en fait après la réalisation de mon
premier film donc c'était il ya trois
ans à peu près ouais je suis pas très
téléphages voir d'assez peu la télé mais
il y avait une émission je crois que
c'était la chaîne il semble nrj 12 en
tout cas qui s'appelait oif
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dedans que la gamme démarre je suis pas
traiter des failles et des mots qui se
trompe de dos et ou représentés par
match grâce à vous c'est une vocation d
une sursaut mais il y croise les doigts
oui oui vraiment si on regarde on bouffe
qui les ont pas coachées regardez où
vous n'avez qu'une envie quitter la
france
[Applaudissements]